a menos de 200 km de las costas del
norte de áfrica marchará de balo es uno
de los puertos de pesca más importantes
de sicilia en el extremo sur de italia
cada año un centenar de barcos de pesca
zarpan de aquí en busca de un producto
valioso
él gambero rosso la gamba roja uno de
los crustáceos más preciados del mundo
único problema la pesca de estas gambas
se hace en alta mar en aguas que libia
reivindica
aguanta pues se apartan de campos en el
mar para los pescadores sicilianos no
extraer o ser atacados por las
autoridades libias fue lo que le ocurrió
al capitán azar o hace unos años cuando
pescaba a 50 millas náuticas de las
costas libias
me dispararon durante cuatro o cinco
horas fue estresante sentir el ruido de
las ametralladoras disparando sin parar
sólo en embarcación con todo esto ya no
se sabe dónde podemos lanzar nuestras
redes salimos a pescar con miedo con
angustia estamos aterrorizados el
mediterráneo se volvió un teatro de
guerra con agua
una guerra desconocida que resuena en
las aguas que separan a libia de italia
un conflicto que francesco mets a pelé
conoce bien
como periodista local le ha hecho
seguimiento a diferentes incautaciones
de embarcaciones de pesca italianas
desde que el coronel gadafi decidió
extender las aguas territoriales de
libia en el 2005 la zona económica libia
declaró una zona exclusiva que se
extiende 62 millas náuticas más allá de
las 12 millas de aguas territoriales
reconocidas desde la costa esto suma 74
millas náuticas que libia reivindica
esto nunca fue aceptado por los otros
gobiernos de los países vecinos de la
zona del mediterráneo incluida italia
porque fue una decisión unilateral y a
partir de ahí comenzaron los problemas y
problema el pasado primero de septiembre
las tripulaciones de dos embarcaciones
pesqueras fueron interceptadas a unas 30
millas náuticas de libia y trasladadas a
benghazi al este del país desde entonces
sólo se conocen estas imágenes de los 18
marinos en detención domiciliaria
la fiscalía de bengasi los acusa de
pescar sin autorización en aguas libias
una situación que preocupa a las
familias el área espera con impaciencia
noticias de su padre mikel el capitán de
la antártida una de las dos
embarcaciones incautadas en una tragedia
pero no es una pesadilla una tragedia
vivimos un período horrible es un
periodo factores lo vivimos con tristeza
angustia y ansiedad permanentes
pero me pregunto cómo está en qué
condiciones como están viviendo western
y cómo está mi obra
una situación aún más complicada por la
política interna libia actualmente dos
autoridades se disputan el poder el
gobierno de unión nacional reconocido
por la onu y con sede en trípoli y una
entidad al este del país apoyada por las
tropas del general jalifa hafter son
ellas las que interceptaron las
embarcaciones italianas si hay una
cuestión geopolítica haftar está
enviándole un mensaje a italia y a la
unión europea no acepta que las grandes
potencias la onu o europa reconozcan
únicamente al gobierno de trípoli para
el estos pescadores son una moneda de
cambio para poder aumentar su peso
político y así ser reconocido a nivel
internacional
sherwin dir consultó al libelo
international alejandro chipión e dirige
un equipo de reporteros en áfrica del
norte en especial venga así que le ha
hecho seguimiento a la detención de los
pescadores italianos desde el primer día
habíamos hablado y comando hablamos con
los comandantes de los guardacostas de
bengasi
y nos dijeron que quieren la liberación
de cuatro ciudadanos libios
en cancelados en italia condenados por
tráfico de seres humanos una especie de
intercambio de prisioneros y studies
cambio el abogado turrisi defiende a uno
de estos cuatro ciudadanos libios
condenado a 30 años de prisión por la
muerte de 49 migrantes en el
mediterráneo durante el trayecto su
cliente dice él no es un traficante sino
un deportista que trataba de emigrar el
puesto
mire este es el contrato del equipo de
fútbol en el que jugaba el equipo de
bengasi de la serie y esta es la prueba
de que este chico era un jugador de
fundando
el jefe de la diplomacia italiana
considera la hipótesis de un intercambio
de prisioneros como un chantaje
inaceptable y las autoridades de bengasi
rechazan hacer cualquier comentario
pero tras bambalinas las negociaciones
continúan
bien
[Aplausos]
mientras tanto las familias de manzana
de valor se movilizan para reclamar el
regreso de sus seres queridos mucho
tiempo ha pasado y tenemos la sensación
de que las negociaciones no avanzan
nuestra paciencia se ha colmado
esperamos que nuestros servicios
secretos haya logren iniciar un
verdadero diálogo para ver un diálogo
activo con unos cuantos globos para
simbolizar la esperanza de un pronto
regreso y el final de una pesadilla para
esta comunidad de pescadores
[Aplausos]